all right ellen
hi helen where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um actually i was
born in
dearborn michigan which is a suburb
right outside of detroit
and tell me about your family growing up
my family is very interesting
we are very diverse
i am the sixth child adopted however i
am the youngest of 14 children
my parents after i was their last baby
they went on to adopt um
older children and we are all different
ethnicities
all of them yes
yeah i go from black asian mulatto white
you name it we it's it's all in my
family interesting family yeah it's it's
it's actually a really cool family you'd
be surprised it kind of looks like when
we take like a family portrait it looks
like some type of like
outside like uh school where everyone
gets together and you would you wouldn't
think that we were all brothers and
sisters
but um you know my parents are very
wealthy and
they they adopted all of us and my
brothers and sisters are my brothers and
sisters regardless if you use the word
adoption or not
so some of you some of you are adopted
and some of them were all adopted
they're all adopted yeah and how would
you describe that childhood
it's up and down it has um i first of
all i was very privileged
you know but um
on the
i don't know like the
lower side of it i would say that i
i went through some struggles with some
of my older brothers
and also
being the youngest there was some
jealousy issues
and
on top of that just
me
having severe learning disabilities you
might not see it at first you know but
when you get to know me
um i do have learning disabilities i've
overcome a lot thank you
god you know because he's really like
helped me and thanks to my parents you
know and a lot of it due to religion
they
they don't want to see
the full front of it they like to put a
cover over it your family your parents
were religious
yes very religious
where it was you know forced and so now
how
i don't believe in religion
i i feel that is is man-made
and but i also believe
in a higher power in which to this day
and always i've i believe in god he has
chosen me and i will always be a child
of his regardless of how far
i am away from him at times in my life
did you finish high school
yes i did 1998 that was one of the best
years of um there that was one of the
best days of my life was actually
walking down the aisle in 1998
because of my learning disabilities
and
the support of my parents they never
held me back they said it might take her
longer but she gets it
you know and that's one of the happiest
days of my life and i'm 42 years old
and where did your life go after you got
out of school
when i graduated high school um
i basically
i felt a sense of freedom
because
given the fact that i came from a family
of 14 we couldn't
get our driver's license until we were
18.
so you know i got my driver's license
right away
and i felt freedom and um that's when
i had my first drink
and before i was a quiet child i was i'm
not going to say i was ever shy but i
was quiet and i observed
you know and i made sure that like you
know
i
in being bullied in everything um
through elementary middle school all the
way through high school being a special
ed having private tutors
you know um my mom and dad like
basically like telling my brothers and
sisters help her through
this or whatnot like
my
my parents were
like
very
protective but
when i got my driver's license that's
basically when i had my first drink and
i know
this you know like an addiction and how
sometimes like going through rehabs and
stuff they always say the light bulb
went off but when i had my first drink
and i felt that buzz and i felt that
like
so it went off in my head and i was like
this is what i've been missing i'm like
finally like
i can talk to people
i feel like a sense of like relief
like i felt like
this is what i've been missing so now i
can you know
you know take alcohol into my picture
take a few shots
now i can go to work and feel okay you
know now i can like you know
feel okay and and that's that's kind of
what
i'm gonna say kind of set my life
um
and i'm gonna i was probably around like
19 years old when i had my first real
alcohol buzz and that was with my um my
big brother and uh well one of my big
brothers and one of my big sisters
and um when i felt that buzz i i loved
it and i was like this is it
and um
i've
been an alcoholic i've had some sober
times here and there but i've been an
alcoholic
for or probably 25 years
and it's
still sticking with me and i've been in
trouble with the law
the good thing is that my father's a
lawyer so you know he
kind of
helped me out with getting away with
you know almost
almost five duis getting bailed out the
next day not not learning my lesson
and that's what where some of the
jealousy comes in with with some of my
brothers and sisters because
my parents would still buy me cars
and let me drive on a you know revoked
license or suspended license
and i grew up privileged however
you know i'm kind of fast forwarding
given the fact where my life's been at
for the past eight and a half years
almost nine
i appreciate my life now
then i did
feeling um
inadequate
feeling um
dumb
and stupid
that
i'm i'm not really gonna amount to
anything you're always gonna have to
depend on mom and dad
you know hiding
family secrets even though i was always
honest
i've been
honest with my parents
but because i feel thank you
but because i feel with
their
religion
and and how much they
i feel like
every
book in in the bible relates to
every life circumstance
doesn't it doesn't matter to me
what matters that
i'm a child of god and i don't have to
say
a prayer
you know
in order for god to accept me into his
kingdom and rather not i
necessarily fully believe in that what i
believe is that
i am a child of god and he will be with
me forever and when i die and i pass
away
nobody knows
no one
what they believe it on is based on man
written scriptures
tell me about your
your routine for drinking is it how how
how much do you drink and how often and
where does it take you
i
i drink every day
from the morning i
wake up
if i don't have anything to drink that's
when the obsession of my mind is like i
gotta get it but for the most part
i always have it
um i i drink very first thing i have to
start my morning out
with alcohol
um
no there are there are times where
i don't necessarily do but as long as i
have it
then i'm gonna be okay because it's
there
um i use it
i use alcohol
to
help me communicate with people
help me feel not so
uptight because i'm i have ocd and i'm
i'm a perfectionist like everything you
know has to be
i'm not gonna say perfect but
with my standards if it's not there then
i'm gonna feel uncomfortable
and alcohol relieves that a little bit
it makes me feel
and understand that
i
i know that
if i'm wearing white tennis shoes with
an alpha that might not necessarily
match that nothing bad is going to
happen when i'm sober
i obsess about that and i think about it
and and i think way more of what other
people think
but in all actuality
i'm
like the least thing that they're
thinking about because they're thinking
about their own life so alcohol
stabilizes you mentally yeah
it makes me feel until it doesn't
probably
i've had my ups and downs whereas i now
at my age
i
i now drink
to
maintain a steady buzz
and to be able to communicate with
people and just feel
overall good
um i used to drink to get [ __ ] up and
to forget about [ __ ] and not face
reality
but when i
went to a rehab back in
2000
and i want to say um
2013
and i learned
how to forgive myself even though i
still hang on to like some [ __ ] or
whatever but i don't take it out on
other people
you know i've learned to
look at my part
in things and own up to it because the
more i do that the easier
you know
things have been and i don't have to
necessarily
drink those sorrows and those pains away
which a lot of people do
even at an older age than i am
not that i'm old or anything but do you
tend to drink too much would you say i
used to yeah i would i would drink
and
completely black out and not remember
anything and when reality was told to me
i was like
oh [ __ ] you know like
i i did that you know like i really did
but i own up to it and it and even if i
don't remember
i still apologize because i know that it
affected that person
and it affected even a relationship and
i'm not saying like an intimate
relationship just a friendship an
acquaintance or anything
you know like i know that
whatever i had done or did
doesn't just affect me and that other
person affects
other people
but today you're using alcohol to
[Music]
i'm i drink alcohol
because first of all i really like the
way it makes me feel
i feel
um more confident i feel
i feel good and i feel like
i
um
just
i could talk to people because when when
i'm not drinking
i overthink
things to the point where i shut down
you just become introverted and i yeah
and i don't talk to people
and
i i don't take it
to like where i used to be where like
i'd keep everything in and then just
totally lash out
but now it's like i just take things in
and i process it
by
writing in my journal
and and
when i'm pissed off sometimes
i take my backpack out i get my journal
out and i just write those [ __ ]
feelings because if i hold it in i know
i know what's gonna happen and it's not
gonna be good
and i'm glad that you know
with the help of
god
he he has shown me
how to ground myself and like
snap back get back into reality so
you're able to control your drinking now
you'd say
i'm gonna say i i think
i think that i do
there could be others out there that say
maybe say not but i've you know had
and and have you know people
in and out of my life where
especially in the past nine months
they have seen me
go from
not
super drunk
and
not wanting to comprehend and facing
reality
where they're like
wow ellen like you seem so much more
calm because you know what
i got
i don't really know how to put it
i
was
in
a relationship
um
with a man
uh for eight and a half years
and
i
made a huge
i made a huge decision to
separate from him
now i mean if i want to get technical we
broke up but it was me that
was a bigger person
and i put that separation
and i had to
look at myself and understand
why
i let
certain behaviors certain things happen
and go on in that relationship
i'm not innocent
by any means
but i endured
a lot more than any
woman
i mean not any woman but you know like
i endured a lot of
things that most women would not put up
with
but
you know and what
i feel i'm a warrior i don't care like
how big the person is who the person is
whatever they are
if there's certain things that come in
my way or
things that i feel is doing harm in my
life especially now
i'll stand up for it
and i don't care
in a good way
if i see a woman
screaming for help
i might assess the situation but if i
feel like she needs help i will be that
person to call 9-1-1
because that's happened to me where no
one did jack [ __ ]
and i'm
on the ground with like
two black eyes and that and and knowing
that
he knows that growing up i was
made fun of and and
ridiculed and you know like telling
like kids saying even even when i was a
senior in high school they said no it
was just because your special ed teacher
read you the questions and gave you
those answers when i was the one that
wrote those answers out she just read it
to me in a sim in a more simpler way
that i would understand
and they were like no you
that you were cheating that's the only
way that you passed
that was like my senior year
in high school
i don't know i know i'm kind of like
backtracking but
where do you live now
right now i stay with um
[Music]
three different people
but you're basically homeless
yeah i i mean i am homeless
but
the the people that i
stay with
are
for the most part
basically struggling
with alcohol as well
but
i
i
am choosing
especially with one of the people that i
stay with not to drink with them
and
um if i do it's a shot here and there
and that's it because i know what it's
going to turn into i can see
how
certain patterns have developed in
my life
with that specific person to the point
where i'm not
i'm choosing again to step up and show
them that i'm not
going to drink with them um
i have three people that i stay with
and yes they're all men but that doesn't
mean that i am you know out you know
messing with any of them i have chosen
for the past nine months
to be on a celibacy
because of the hurt
and
just
given the fact that i
if i you know have like a sexual
encounter with a man
or if that's all they want then
i'm not going to go there and i draw the
line
and
i put feelings behind
having you know
sexual encounters with a man their head
there's feelings behind that i can't
just up and like just [ __ ] someone
that that's back in late when i was like
18 19 years old you know like
i put feelings because that's the kind
of person that i am and i'm not gonna
like
i can't do that
and even today even today when i when i
was coming here there was a guy that
drove his car up twice with with the guy
that you know was i came here with
trying to like tell me some story of
like how i met him daddy that you know
and they come with me and all this [ __ ]
and i'm like dude what the [ __ ] man like
you know um
and as a female and being homeless there
are times where that comes into play and
there might be times where i'm desperate
and i do need money and i might put
myself in a situation like that
but i know
to grab my [ __ ] bag and just bow
and i have put myself in situations
that
are not good
but
for me
i just i call it
my circumstance
my my life where i'm at right now i have
to sometimes
settle for
certain situations or put up
with stuff that i ordinarily would not
ever
put up with
and
i think that's what makes me stronger
and
the ability that nine months ago i was
able to
stand up
to the man that i was with
and we have
um
we have an eight-year-old now she's
eight
how many kids do you have one
and
we did what was in the best interest and
we gave her up for adoption
open adoption so i can still see her
i um
given the fact that i stood up for
myself and i said you will never again
hit me
or touch me
or take advantage of me and in any way
shape or form and i did that and since
then
as much as i miss him and it would be
weird if i didn't
it would be weird being with someone for
eight and a half years
to not miss them to not still love them
to not even think about them
because i because i still do love him
and i hope that he's okay
but i had to put
separation between
him and i in order for me to grow and
change and to spend a bit
it's been hard but the changes that i've
made in my life
have been
so much better and they're making me
stronger and i stand up for myself
and i'm not
you know hiding behind
the truth in the in the reality because
sometimes i would lie
or i would
fabricate a story which would someone
kind of telling the truth and not
and i own up to that
and that
to me
shows growth
and for me not looking him up on
facebook or
you know like calling the gel see if
he's okay i don't do that
and i put that i tell myself don't
because the motherfucker's not looking
for me either
my birthday went past his birthday went
past holidays went and passed our
daughter's birthday when passed nothing
nothing do you see her
i do i get pictures i could do
i could be doing a lot better
but i do
i don't
carry shame
of
putting her or giving her up for
adoption because i got i got to pick the
lady
that you know she's with and um and i
would have never picked anyone else but
her
i got my daughter taken away
when
and i usually don't
tell people this because again like it's
shame is
guilt but
i got her taken away after she
after she was about a month old
maybe just barely a month old
i got her taken away
her father again was locked up in jail i
gave birth to my daughter by myself
no friends no family i'm not feeling
sorry for myself or anything like that
because i didn't tell anybody
that i was pregnant
i didn't tell anyone so it's not like i
you know and i
you know my pregnancy was very easy not
like most women that you know
go through hardships and stuff
i uh
i got her taken away about
when she was about a month old
and um
i
went through
several
rehabs but i never finished them
but i did fight for her and my daughter
loves me
she loves when i sing to her she loves
you know like and when whenever i visit
with her
she um
she'll tell her mom
she's like
i just i just want to stay with ellen i
don't want i don't want to she calls me
she calls me by my first name which is
also a thing that i went through therapy
for does she know you're her mom yes
yeah she knows she's adopted her mother
is is a is a black woman
and my daughter gets her hair braided
with beads all of it i mean she she is
so cute she's like minnie me
and um and she has some of the um
learning disabilities that i have and
but she she's a badass she is a
she she is so cute
and um
she uh
yeah my daughter knows
who who i am and she knows who her
father is and she knows that she's
adopted which i think is the right thing
because when um when i was a child i i
knew right away that i was adopted
my parents had um have a book that's
called um
why was i adopted you know and my
parents are both white
you know i'm um
partially hispanic italian
and um armenian do you know anything
about your biological parents yeah
biological you know my parents are both
like dutch white but were they did they
have problems with alcohol or anything
yeah they they both were alcoholics
and i think that's part of the reason
maybe why i wanted to see what drinking
was because my parents would always tell
me well your parents were both
alcoholics so don't ever drink don't
ever drink but i had older brothers and
sisters that
um were drinking went to parties and i
was the baby you know and they would
sometimes invite me as like you know
like you know they their their friends
would like french braid my hair and like
you know like i was like the little girl
that was like you know everyone's like
friend or whatever meanwhile you know
they were drinking having a good time
because i think my parents wouldn't
think that that's what they were doing
considering that they were taking me
with them
drinking and driving home or going to a
madonna concert
you know and
not telling my my mom and dad because oh
i was with them so you know but i would
get dropped off and taken care of by one
of their friends while they went and did
that you know what i mean like and so i
saw the party and i saw that i wanted to
do that
and and given the fact that well you
know both your parents were alcoholics
you know like
and
yeah it's just i feel like
there were there was always temptation
in my life um
given the fact that
i i wanted a drink i wanted to see what
it would feel like and like i said
earlier like when i
had like my first alcoholic buzz
i
i felt it i knew i knew like
that's what i was missing out on
ellen what do you say
is uh
some of your what are you most afraid of
at this point in your life
i'm most afraid of um
disappointing people
and
because i love i love my mom and dad and
i love what they've done for me
but i
i put you know there's distance you know
there's like times where i don't talk to
them because
i just i feel like i'm going to be dubby
downer
you know like
i feel like they
don't
accept me like
for who i am and i've told them
for a long time you know like i'm a
bisexual woman and they
they
they won't believe it they think i'm
making it up or
this is you know like that's a sin i'm
going to hell
you know and
the fact that like
i
the way that i'm living
they they cast so much judgment on it do
you feel shame about your situation
no no
i feel like i can do better
i feel like that's that's different
i feel like i can do better but i don't
feel
ashamed i don't feel like
the way i'm living is
is
harmful to me
i don't
feel that
especially the
more recent friends that i have found
god has put them in my life for a reason
because of given my separation from the
man that i was with
every person that god has put into my
life
has thus far
been
good to me
and even the ones that struggle with
their own addictions and stuff
they still got my back and i still got
their back regardless of
whether or not
me and that person have discrepancies
and things
or may not get along
i i believe that
i and i know that i appreciate life so
much more
now
than
i did when i was growing up being
privileged i never learned my lesson i
got bailed out of everything my father's
a lawyer my mom's a registered nurse you
know like the head of the er department
you know like i grew up in a mansion you
know i had
everything given to me
and
i didn't appreciate it
i didn't see it
i didn't understand the amount of money
that i was making back then as to now
where i'm at and i appreciate every
[ __ ] penny i have
and i appreciate the fact that i can
wake up in the morning
sometimes not all the time
and look at myself in the mirror or
have a bathroom that i you know
can you know use
i don't have to piss outside
don't have to worry about oh
oh that laundry mat might let me and
they might not because they use their
bathroom too much
i appreciate those little small things
so much more
and it
it makes me stronger and it makes me
feel
like
there's
more to my life than
doing the thing that my parents want me
to do and
get married and have kids and you know
have a husband that does that that that
i don't want that what i want is for me
to be who i am
and be happy and it's been a long time
and i mean i might be crying right now
but this is good for me like crying is
healing
and um
for where my life is at right now
i'm so much happier than i was even nine
months ago
and i feel that
god has
always been there and he always will
and
the more like faith and trust i put in
him
the more easier it gets but i don't want
to get complacent because that's when
he's going to throw that curveball
to test
all right ellen thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah
thank you
you